everybody this is gary vaynerchuk thanks
for coming to the new gary gamescom
video everyday appreciate when you guys
stop by and there's a very intriguing
lyric that has always SAT my head and it
says cash rules everything around me
right green little moo tank for kids I
know you at that pub um and you look so
funny I've actually thought about that
and my big belief is with social media
and new media went to 10 whatever you
want to call it a new business world we
live in where the platforms have been
redefined cash has actually been punched
directly in the mouth for the first time
in a long time and sweat equity and
caring and your hustle and niches are
really what's in play it's the content
and the caring our king and queen now
right and what really it makes me
believe is not cash rules everything
around me but the new slang term cloud
rules everything around me the whole
infrastructure of this connected world
is actually the ruler now because this
platform has utilized cash out and has
created situation where if you pump out
enough awesome content and you give
enough crap about your audience and you
work hard enough you can become a very
sneaky very quick competitor to the
person that is owned or been the
dominant financial force in your niche